yeah what's that uh google uh the
russian film that's been in production
for like 50 years
just type that in type that into google
there's this i watched this thing uh
this video from a trustee guide it's
about this video yeah about this russian
animation producer who
draws every single like frame oh i think
i know you're talking about he's like
the walt disney of russia right yeah
yeah yeah yeah he's super acclaimed and
famous
like his animations are insane yeah it's
amazing but he's been working on this
one animation for like a ridiculous
amount of years
right it's just like it's never going to
be finished yeah at the rate because
he's like he's like nearly dying he's
very very old and he's like not even
halfway
and it's like 30 40 years in or
something really long
what what kind of movie is he making
it's uh it's it's it's animated it's an
animated story about i think it's called
the raincoat or something it's uh
the overcoat that's it yeah the overcoat
is that what it's called yeah it's how
many years have been in production for
four
years has he released like previews or
is it yeah yeah he just like said guys
i'm working on this video
yes it's coming out the yellow like
delay thing comes out every 10 years
it's like you guys give give me another
10 years
people reply to it i put work off to
watch this what the [ __ ]
imagine youtubers be like guys i'm
working on something big it's big
ten years later guys i'm still working
on it
they've released portions of the film
that you can watch and it is it is very
beautiful yeah but it's also like really
sad because it's like oh this thing this
drawing this set of drawing that has
consumed this man's life yeah and that
has drove this man to insanity yeah and
ruined all of his relationships and
everything because he's also like a dick
to everyone because of course every
director ever is a massive dick of
course um yeah and he's like really
apparently very harsh works insane hours
makes his wife work like crazy as well
and right yeah how's he getting paid
uh i think donations
um and kickstarter
indiegogo
all the works you know
god he must have gone through like every
donation platform known to man if we
started 40 years ago so they don't have
any technology in the studio they refuse
to have any technology because of course
they do and they do all by hand but it's
like it's like it's like at what point
when you're making something for so long
are you like all right come on
come on [ __ ] off come on finish it come
on stop now this is inject yeah sort out
sort out mate
start your life out come on
there's more to life than just this one
project well you know it goes past the
point where it's just like you are just
letting this consume you to a point
where you're not creating any more it's
just it's just taking a whole just an
addiction yeah yeah yeah yeah you're not
this isn't healthy because
you're not going to finish it and
at that point no matter what you release
is never going to be worth the amount of
how years of your life yeah yeah
i mean there's only a few things that
are worth 40 years don't get me wrong it
looks amazing but it's also very sad
hearing the story of this guy and it
just takes over his life yeah like i
mean he must really love it i'm sure
that's an understatement i don't know i
feel like it's not
the same i think it's an obsession is it
desperation i don't think i don't know
it's probably one of those things where
it's like it's definitely not healthy
yeah yeah i mean
you know it's not like a passion it
probably is passion but i think it's
only a package i think it's obsession
which is you know obsession is different
from passion what's like the longest you
guys have ever worked on a single
project i mean because like you recently
just uploaded your cosplay video you
know yeah very good very good um because
i remember every few weeks or something
you'd be like yeah i'm going to a shoot
it's the cosplay video and i swear that
would like that went on for like a
[ __ ] year or something yeah there was
a year yeah yeah it took a long time
yeah i mean it's all right it's good
it's good fun it wasn't true is that the
longest thing you've worked on yeah not
hours put in but right as in like time
and number of shoots yeah it was the
most yeah you know and it's fine i mean
it wasn't too hands-on just kind of
getting the edit down was difficult
what's like the most you've ever put
into one project then
oh my gosh
i don't know okay i'll i'll go first
though
huh is yours no no no it's like the most
i've ever put in was [ __ ] must be
like 10 years ago or something now i
made this top 20 list called like the
top coolest anime characters of all time
or something along those lines right
that sounds like a 2010 youtube video
yeah how did this take you years okay so
get this um it was eight parts
it was
it was it was an eight part series right
because i would spend part featuring ten
characters no 20 characters oh okay yeah
yeah so so every part would contain like
two or three characters and each part
would be at least like 15 to 20 minutes
long right right and i was working i was
working i was working on this one single
project basically throughout university
i basically wasn't uploading anything
but this one [ __ ] series yeah and i
realized about two videos in after i'd
spent like months just working on two
videos i'm just like
i've made a massive mistake
i did finish it it took me and like it
took me an entire year to finish right
and it took me an entire year to finish
and i remember
when i finished it was basically when i
graduated from university
and i put the script of this top 20 list
next to my dissertation and the top 20
list was twice the length of my
dissertation that i had worked with my
last year
so my dissertation which i spent an
entire year working on was half half
like the length of this [ __ ] youtube
video series that i had worked on in
that same year
so uh that was so good yeah and i don't
know at some point
you you kind of like
it's it's not it's not motivation that's
keeping you going because when you have
a project that big you just want to
finish it just so you can [ __ ] figure
it out yeah
you just want to start yeah but you
can't you started yeah the yowie
audiobook took me like a month of like
uh like probably like a month at least
five days a week eight eight to twelve
hours
non-stop yeah reading this [ __ ] book
over and over again yeah non-stop read
that book so many times i i hate it i
hate it now i can't look at it it drives
me insane i like it i like it a lot but
i hate it because because like you get
to about 50 60 of the way in and you're
just like this is this is [ __ ] i'm done
i'm not doing this yeah and then you're
like but i gotta finish yeah i just like
there's there's just something about
having
an unfinished project that just 50
seconds
yeah
people can be like oh where was where's
ava bridge 2.0 and i'm just like i did
the first film that to me is like a
completed completed project that's why
part of the big reason i didn't want to
didn't want to continue that was because
i didn't want to put that upon myself
again to start a project that i knew was
going to take [ __ ] years to finish
and that's what like that's that's what
excites me but that's what also scares
me the biggest like the most when it
comes to taking on a big project because
i've got like a lot of different ideas
for a lot of big projects i eventually
want to do but just knowing what it's
like where you're like excited you're
motivated for like the first half and
then that just peters off and you start
hating your project and start hating
yourself and just like i just want to
get this done yeah that's me is just
that that is like such an awful grind
what about you joe what was your longest
i don't know i mean so every video
stands out as being like gruelling oh
like anything you worked on
music-wise or anything i mean music-wise
i guess like my first album took yeah it
was like two years how long were you
working on that album for uh the first
album i took like two years it's like on
and off right yeah that was on an offer
because that was just like a side
problem so you'd throw a little bit here
and there yeah yeah yeah it's like
whenever i felt like doing it because
it's not really like you know my career
isn't dependent on yeah
when did you feel like it was ready to
like be released you know um because
because because i've had side projects
like that as well there where you do
like a certain percentage and then you
realize wait a minute this i might
actually get to the end of this yeah i
might actually be able to i mean the
first time i was like eight tracks and i
think by like track six i was like okay
is this enough for an album or should i
add more
not sure and then yeah and then like
after that like it was kind of like a
rush of like inspiration because it's
like you see the you start to see the
final product right and you're like the
goal is right there like i just need i
just need to run to it now yeah um the
last five percent is actually really fun
when it's all started yeah the last five
percent is like hell yeah yeah but um i
don't know in terms of videos not not
too sure i mean i think the reason why a
lot of my videos take so long is because
either
me with whatever i'm working with takes
a long time to just come back to our
life a lot of it is just like waiting
yeah right like so i did the
i did that video with ladybeard where we
like run around the uh like a figurine
like factory and like we did that video
that took that video took like eight
months oh god we're counting time just
getting like prep yeah it's a different
thing
tell me you're a japanese youtuber
without telling me you're a japanese
youtuber like that video took me eight
months but seven of those months was
just waiting for them to give me the
okay yeah and forgive me a good date to
start and then the actual shoot took
like a day and a half so it's like yeah
you know i i feel like in terms of like
just sheer working on a video uh time
like maybe
i don't know a month is like max i can't
tell you which video it is but i have
like a couple of videos like that i feel
that with trash day specials though as
well